even though they've been friends for
years jennifer aniston learned something
new about her former friend's co-star
matthew perry
during the reunion special yeah so
matthew who of course portrayed chandler
bingham friends
he revealed that he used to go to
convulsions
if the studio audience didn't laugh at
his jokes when they taped the show so
this is what he revealed to me
i felt like i was going to die if they
didn't laugh and it's not healthy for
sure
but i would sometimes and i would sweat
and just go into convulsions if i didn't
get the laugh i was supposed to get i
would freak out
yeah aniston reacted to this news last
week on the today show saying
i didn't understand the level of anxiety
and self-torture
that was put on matthew perry if he
didn't get that laugh and the
devastation that he felt
but it makes a lot of sense oh
i know so that's my reaction too are you
surprised that he was able to keep this
a secret because even in the reunion
special when he revealed that lisa
kudrow very quickly was like
you never told us that yeah i mean
especially then people didn't really
understand anxiety
um and we still don't we barely
understand it
people are finally getting to the point
where they say just in a regular
conversation hey i have anxiety or this
is making me anxious
we're finally kind of normalizing that
but to be you know performing again at
that such a high level
friends is such a huge show he's such a
huge celebrity you know what comes with
that
in dealing with anxiety i just feel for
him i can personally relate
i struggle with anxiety but because i
have the tools and the knowledge
i can navigate my career fine i can't
imagine
having anxiety at that time when no one
knows anything about it
obviously you want to be funny amongst
your peers funny
you know for your fans for the you know
the show audience and whatnot
it's a lot of pressure for one person
i'm just glad that he's
he pushed through it and i'm glad that
he's speaking out about it because i'm
sure it's going to help a lot of people
yeah joey's saying poor matthew life
must have been hard
um no he's actually joking he's saying
making a million dollars now so here
here's the thing i have a comment about
really honest i hear this time and time
again
it's like people aren't allowed to be
human just because they make a lot of
money
i think people forget that this is a
live audience
we watch it at home we hear the laughter
you know some people think
i just don't think people equate having
a live audience and watching performers
on stage
that's hard um and
you know to come out to nail your lines
the comedy
um and look everybody was funny on that
show right but the character of chandler
he's so
dry so quick-witted like i would say he
had the funniest line so it makes me so
sad
that he ripped himself up because he's
so good
even if he wasn't good he shouldn't put
himself up but it makes me sad and then
sad that he couldn't people because as
you and i when you can't share those
things you keep it inside
and then it festers on faster investors
he's talked about health problems in the
past he's talked about substance abuse
in the past
you know and to think that that could
have been related to the anxiety that he
was dealing with on a regular basis this
is so unfortunate so i agree with you
i'm happy he's
speaking out about it yeah i'm happy
speaking out about it too
i think it's super important that we
just talk about anxiety in general and
yeah okay he made a lot of money
he has enough money to go see therapists
and deal with what
and all that with what that but you know
what when you're making a lot of money
and you have a lot of eyeballs there's a
lot of pressure
and we're all humans at the end of the
day i agree with you and obviously you
know we care what people think whether
we say we don't or not you know we want
to make people laugh we want to make
people happy
and um you know i just feel for him but
i'm glad he said something too yeah